це є питання не самого стефанчука він є
найбільш безхребетним і безініціативним
головою Верховної Ради все іде до офісу
президента саме там регулюють всі
абсолютно питання відряджень а народних
депутатів членів Кабінету Міністрів і
так далі тобто офіс президента замкнув
на собі по факту а рішення Хто буде
їхати за кордон а хто ні що є в принципі
втручанням в парламентаризм але робиться
це руками керівництва Верховної Ради
України насправді це є порушенням власне
закону Про статус народного депутата
України і конституції е порушення 351
статті Кримінального кодексу України
який передбачає кримінальну
відповідальність за перешкоджання е
законній діяльності народного депутата
України